a un número x le vamos a sumar una
pequeña cantidad que será vamos a ver
aquí como a x le estamos sumando a
benasque el número y le restamos la
misma cantidad pequeña que fue vamos a
ver aquí tenemos y le vamos a restar la
misma cantidad que es a con ello
conseguiremos x prima y prima x prima
prima como se muestre la recta numérica
de abajo de hecho ya se los fui
mostrando esto es muy sencillo qué
información describe correctamente la
distancia entre x y jeff prima vamos a
ver que aquí tenemos diferentes digamos
anunciados de información que nos dan
sobre x prima vamos a ver cuáles de
ellos son correctos y seleccionaremos
todos los que aplican vamos a tomar la
primera tenemos que la distancia entre x
y que prima es mayor que el valor
absoluto de x
jeff vamos paso a paso y primero vamos a
sacar con es la distancia entre x y
primas les parece bien tenemos aquí que
la distancia entre x prima
será ésta
la colocaremos en rojo
y tenemos esta distancia entre x y prima
ahora nos están preguntando si esta
distancia es mayor que el valor absoluto
de x - y si nos vamos a nuestra gráfica
podemos ver que x se encuentra en esta
posición mientras que james está aquí y
con esto podemos ver que es un número
mayor que x están de acuerdo dado que ya
está a la derecha de nuestra recta
numérica
así es que si a x le quitamos esto nos
dará un número negativo entonces nos
damos cuenta que tomaremos el valor
absoluto de esta distancia
así es que realmente buscaremos la
diferencia absoluta entre estos dos
números es decir el valor absoluto de x
menos 10
será la distancia entre xy llevamos a
marcarla con otro color vamos a marcar
la distancia entre x
este será el valor absoluto de x
menos bien
y con esto tenemos ahora sí la
suficiente información para poder hacer
una comparación tenemos que la distancia
entre x prima
este que tenemos en color rojo es mayor
que el valor absoluto de x si pues con
esto podemos ver que no es verdad vamos
a marcarlo como negativo dado que
naturalmente aquí vemos que la distancia
que existe entre x y prima es menor que
esta distancia que tenemos
correspondiente al valor absoluto de x
menos vamos entonces con esta segunda
opción nos dice que la distancia entre x
y james vamos a volver la marca del rojo
para que no se nos olvide la distancia
entre x
prima que es esta que tenemos ya marcaba
es menor que el valor absoluto de x
menos que de hecho ya lo teníamos aquí
marcado se dan cuenta y sí
x mi prima es una distancia mucho menor
que la que está entre x y podemos
entonces considerar que ésta es correcta
vamos a palomear la siguiente opción que
tenemos de información
la distancia entre x prima una vez más
la marcaremos en rojo
es igual al valor absoluto de x
menos a uno esto está muy sencillo dado
que ya teníamos la distancia del valor
absoluto de x menos ya que vamos a
marcar aquí como la información que ya
tenemos
pero ahora le restamos a vamos a
regresarnos la misma cantidad que
tenemos de camps por lo tanto la
distancia que nos quedará del valor
absoluto de x menos menos a será
equivalente a esta distancia que va de x
allí priman entonces podemos decir que
la distancia entre x y prima claro que
es igual qué valor absoluto de x
jeff menos a lo podemos ver aquí vamos a
palomear esta también como correcta y
vámonos con la última opción tenemos la
distancia entre x
prima es igual que el valor absoluto de
x prima menos vamos a volver a
desmenuzar esta información tenemos la
distancia entre x prima que ya conocemos
y hemos marcado con rojo anteriormente y
esto nos está pidiendo que la comparemos
con x prima menos el valor absoluto otra
manera en la que podemos pensar de esta
distancia que va de x allí prima pues la
podemos pensar como el valor absoluto
que tenemos d
- y prima
si nosotros reescribimos esta
información en términos de x 10 días
podemos decir que x prima
será igual a equis
más a están de acuerdo iniciamos en x le
sumamos a y entonces llegamos a x x
prima es igual a x + a si nosotros lo
escribimos esto aquí tendríamos entonces
el valor absoluto
de esta x prima que ya conocimos como x
+
a lo cual le arrestaremos
d
y esto es igualdad
x +
menos
valor absoluto estamos bien ahora que
significa prima vamos a sacarlo de aquí
en términos de g
vamos a tomar otro color que tal el
anaranjado tendremos entonces que ye
prima será igual a
- ah y esto está muy claro teníamos un
ayer le restamos la cantidad de a y
ahora quedamos en prima si sustituimos
prima de acuerdo a esta información
sustituiremos esto por esto vamos a
reescribir la valor absoluto de x menos
este desglose que tenemos donde prima es
igual
- ah
y volvemos a cerrar el símbolo de valor
absoluto con el color rojo que teníamos
previamente listo si nosotros tenemos
esta expresión matemática después de un
símbolo de menos entonces vamos a
reescribir la de tal manera que tengamos
x menos
más
valor absoluto vamos bien ahora si
nosotros acomodamos de tal manera que
nos queden las variables digamos en el
mismo orden tendríamos x más o menos o
lo que es igual a equis
más
bien sólo estoy acomodando adecuadamente
- que es exactamente la misma
información que tenemos del lado
izquierdo el valor absoluto de x más a
menos es igual al valor absoluto de x
más o menos james y con esto tenemos
entonces la última respuesta como
correcta
tenemos tres de estos cuatro enunciados
como información correcta respecto a la
distancia entre x prima